une autre entreprise à présent quielle
doit rembourser 15 millions d'euros à
l'État souvenez-vous c'estes récifarm 15
millions d'euros que l'État lui avait
alloué pour son développement dans le
cadre du Plan francerance or la société
suédoise veut finalement fermer son site
de monde d'ici 2025 plus de 220 salariés
voit leur emploi menacés alors ce matin
une centaine d'entre eux ont débrayé et
manifesté devant l'entreprise pour
demander des explications à la direction
et un vrai dialogue social romain
Delville les a rencontré
les salariés de réfarm craignent le
scénario du pire pour leur emploi et
pour le site de mon 320 salariés il y a
2 ans la prise en main par un fond de
pension suédois en 2020 un plan de
départ volontaire en avril dernier un
nouveau directeur qui est à peine arrivé
il y a quelques semaines annonce la
fermeture du site il y a 2 ans on avait
le projet moderna avec une installation
du projet Atlas on a une ligne qui est
neuve qui ne fonctionne pas et on a vu
du monde passé des professionnels du
consulting des gens qui étaient là pour
nous motiver avec des groupes qui
étaient là pour nous euh pour nous
perfectionner on va dire dans notre
travail de production et puis du jour en
lendemain en fait il y a plus rien on
nous a on apprend que la ligne elle est
endormission et en fait bah voilà quoi
on on était 500 et 1 an après on est 227
et sur les 227 là on apprend que dans
moins de 8 mois voir avant cet été il y
a ça se trouve plus personne lors du
débrayage ce matin des salariés parlent
de violence sociale selon eux la
direction est sour de dialogue c'est que
là on a beaucoup de jeunes quand même
qui sont là qu'on a remis sur le site et
voilà ils ont tousah une vie de famille
tout ça là 227 emplois en moins ces
gens-là bah oui tout le monde a peur
qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir surtout sur
le marché de l'emploi c'est un peu
bouché maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire après depuis les années 50 le site
a connu une succession de propriétaires
laboratoire Roger bon Ron Poulin
astrazena
cette fois les représentants ont le
sentiment que R farm préfère fermer que
vendre le site de mon nous on est
attacher à notre site c'est pas
l'enseigne qui est là-bas qui fait la
valeur du site ce sont les salariés qui
sont autour de moi qui font la valeur de
ce site et c'est ça nous on est prêt à
nous relever les manches à se relever
les manches avec un nouvel investisseur
sérieux avec un beau projet industriel
voilà on sera là on l'accueillera
convenablement on écoutera ce qu'il a
nous proposer c'est ça que on veut
démontrer on n'est pas pour la fermeture
du site on n'est pas pour avoir un
billet on est là pour conserver nos
emplois après un rendez-vous en
préfecture les représentants du
personnel se rendront au ministère de
l'Économie demain pour éplaider leur
cause et l'indépendance pharmaceutique
de la
France